viele sagen sie fühlen sich also mit den
aktuell zugelassenen impfstoffen nicht
wohl das ging manchen zu schnell in der
zulassung was ist ihre antwort darauf
ganz am anfang ganz ehrlich hätte ich
das verstanden weil man ja wirklich nur
die studienergebnisse da mit aus beiden
studien von den mba studien je 40.000
menschen die auf circa studien bisher
weniger aber nicht zwischenzeit haben
wir doch wirklich sehr sehr viele daten
wir haben weltweit 7,5 milliarden
menschen inzwischen geimpft etwa eine
milliarde in systemen wie wirklich hoch
reguliert sind wo wir jede nebenwirkung
ganz anschauen und da denke ich mir so
ein bisschen gut eine größere datenbasis
dafür dass die impfstoffe sicher sind
gibt es ja nicht und sicher das muss man
einfach immer sagen heißt nie 100
prozent aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ich eine schwere impfnebenwirkungen
bekomme ist wirklich wirklich selten die
ist so in dem bereich gehabt dass ich
vom blitz getroffen werde in etwa und
das ist einfach extrem unwahrscheinlich
was auch häufig kommt sind fragen zu
langzeitfolgen da habe ich auch eine bei
uns bei youtube gesehen von speed
schiller sie fragt oder er fragt wo
bleiben die daten zu longo wird ohne die
daten kann man nicht nachrechnen wie man
in meiner altersgruppe 25 scheint die
person zu sein statistisch besser dran
steht bei einer sterberate von 0,01 ohne
impfung ganz zu schweigen davon dass ich
keiner risikogruppe angehöre die frage
ist wo bleiben die daten zu longo wird
was ja eine
was er aber eine tourismus kurz mal klar
machen das wäre ja natürlich eine eine
folge einer kur wird erkrankung also
vielleicht müssen wir das in zwei fragen
spalten also erst mal wo bleiben die
daten zur longo witt fragt bachelor
ich kann die frage gut verstehen und ich
finde sie auch sehr berechtigt wenn
jemand der junge ist sagt na ja wenn ich
mich jetzt impfen lasse dann ist es für
mich persönlich ja gar nicht so ein
großer schutz weil selbst wenn ich mich
infizieren ein risiko schwer krank zu
werden gering ist ihm kann man da nur
antworten das ist schon richtig dass ist
gering aber es ist auch nicht null und
es ist immer noch ein ganzes stück höher
als das risiko einer impfung da gibt es
inzwischen auch wenn also bahn sich die
leben von einer sehr gute daten dazu wo
man ganz genau geschaut wo ist denn das
risiko nach der impfung höher und wofür
es das risiko nach der infektion höher
und das einzige wofür das risiko nach
der info höher ist ist eine
lymphknotenschwellung zu entwickeln das
muss man auch ganz klar sagen alle
anderen dinge sind immer noch das risiko
nach einer infektion höher trotzdem kann
ich in standpunkt verstehen und viele
junge menschen argumentieren natürlich
so dass sie dann gut mein persönliches
risiko ist gering
manche sagen ich habe jetzt niveau ist
oder ich sehe eine gesellschaftliche
verpflichtung weil ich möchte natürlich
diejenigen die jetzt ein höheres risiko
haben mit schützen dass es die zweite ja
der zweite grund natürlich warum man
sich impfen lassen sollten eben jetzt
den persönlichen risiko aber wenn man
jetzt wissen möchte außer der akuten
infektionen das besteht denn für ein
longo mit risiko haben wir in
deutschland tatsächlich keine guten
zahlen ich persönlich schaue mir dann
immer die zahlen aus england an da gibt
es zum glück gute zahlen und ich gehe
mal davon aus dass engländer sehr
ähnlich sind die deutsche da gibt es
eine sehr große
revolution mit über 200.000 menschen in
jeder gruppe und die vergleicht menschen
die kobelt 19 gehabt haben und menschen
die gruppe 19 nicht gehabt haben und
schaut dann nach den sogenannten long
cobit folgen ist total wichtig diese
kontrollgruppe zu haben weil viele der
symptome sind doch ein bisschen
unspezifisch und wenn man da rein schaut
dann sieht man dass die gruppe
derjenigen die über 17 jahre alt ist ein
doch erhöhtes risiko für long cobit hat
und der steigt mit zunehmendem alter bis
zu etwa 70 jahre an und es ist bei
frauen deutlich höher als es bei männern
ist also das als argument für sich
benutzen möchte um sich selber auch zu
überzeugen da ist es schon wert mal in
so eine datenbasis hineinzuschauen und
dann aber auch noch einmal die frage
nach den zeit folgen vor denen sich
viele sorgen die eben noch nicht geimpft
sind
ich kann natürlich über
die folgen über eine zeit nur etwas
sagen solange ich auch die
langzeitbeobachtung habe es lange nicht
das weiß
man weiß aus der entwicklung von ganz
ganz vielen impfstoffen wie man ja über
die jahrzehnte gemacht hat dass
langzeitfolgen von impfstoffen in
der regel innerhalb von zwei wochen
auftreten aber bis spätestens zwei
monate nach der impfung auftreten
deswegen hat man auch schon bei den
initialen studien gesagt stopp wir
machen keine zulassung nach weniger als
zwei monaten sondern wir möchten bitte
drei monate nach beobachtungszeit um zu
wissen kommt dann auch irgendwas da ist
nichts gekommen und die zahl der vielen
geimpften mehr gibt es ja auch schon
seit einem jahr hat auch da gibt es
keinen hinweis dass irgendetwas
nachgekommen wäre an
langzeiteffekte insofern glaube ich mit
jedem jahr mit jedem geimpften und mit
jedem monat länger zeit haben werden wir
da natürlich auch immer noch sicherer
was ich jetzt häufig in den kommentaren
gelesen habe gerade von menschen die
jetzt die jünger sind dann möchte ich
mal einen kommentar stellvertretend
vorlesen ferry die bei youtube möchte
wissen warum sollte man sich als
21-jähriger kerngesunder mensch der sich
regelmäßig testet impfen lassen wenn man
durch die tests die anderen menschen
mehr schützt
das ist wieder so ein bisschen das
argument der gerade auch schon hatten
wenn ich für mich persönlich keine hohe
gefährdung sehe warum soll ich das tun
ich nehme einmal ganz gern so das
beispiel des sicherheitsgurtes im auto
nichts ihren sicherheitsgurt im auto
auch deshalb an weil
ich wenn ich dann einen unfall haben
sollte indem ich mich schwerer verletzen
könnte geschützt bin das heißt noch
nicht dass ich diesen unfall haben oder
ihn vielleicht wahrscheinlicher habe
weil ich weil ich den sicherheitsgurt
frage sondern ich möchte mich für diese
situation einfach besser vorbereiten und
da geht es wirklich nur um einen
eigenschutz da geht es nicht um den
schutz anderer menschen dem ich jetzt
bei einer info noch als als nebeneffekt
habe im auto der sicherheitsgurt kann
mich auch verletzt es besteht die
möglichkeit genauso selten wie die
nebenwirkungen oder schwere
nebenwirkungen einer impfung besteht die
möglichkeit dass sich durch das tragen
eines sicherheitsgurtes verletzt werde
trotzdem tragen wir alle sicherheitsgurt
weil wir sagen das schützt uns eben für
den fall wo wir mal einen schweren und
wann haben sollten und wenn wir auf die
intensivstationen schauen und unsere
erfahrungen aus den verschiedenen bällen
die erste welle und jetzt gerade auch
wieder die grippewelle sind halt schon
leider auch junge menschen die das
trifft es ist viel seltener als ältere
menschen aber es liegt ja auch eben der
35-jährige skitourengeher mit familie wo
man sagt bohr den hec eigentlich nie
treffen deutschen rein statistisch
gesehen
treffen tut ihm aber doch da muss jeder
für sich natürlich so ein bisschen
selber entscheiden der eigenschutz ist
durchs test 0 gegeben der schutz für
andere den kann ich natürlich auch
durchs testen deutlich verbessern
und es gibt viele imker kritische
menschen also auf jeden fall menschen
die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind die
sagen sie wollten wollen auf einen
sogenannten tod impfstoff warten zum
beispiel von nowaks die heute die eu
zulassung beantragt haben das dauert
aber dann noch eine weile hier auch nur
stellvertretend schreibt jason bei
youtube zdf kannst du mal sagen wann der
tod impfstoff kommt vielleicht damals
ihre einschätzung zu diesem sogenannten
tod impfstoff
also
dessen von proteinen basierter impfstoff
es ist auch kein ganz klassischer tod
impfstoff nach klassischer tod im stoff
wäre wenn ich das virus an züchter und
dann ab tötete und dann in diese
impfstoffe gibt es in china die
funktionieren aber leider sehr sehr
schlecht deswegen würde ich die
überhaupt nicht in erwägung ziehen
dieser nowaks impfstoff ist ein
proteinbasierter ein klassischer
impfstoff der das protein in so kleinen
armen partikel gepackt hat damit es eben
sehr gut wirkt und der ist tatsächlich
nach den studien genauso wirksam wie die
m r innenstadt nämlich zu 95 prozent
also das ist sicherlich ein sehr guter
impfstoff und eine alternative für
diejenigen die sagen das konzept america
im stoff gefällt mir nicht so gut ich
möchte lieber so einen klassischen
protein impfstoff haben der aber dann
natürlich auch wirksam sein sollte und
es ist dieser impfstoff an studien
zufolge wenn man über breite erfahrungen
nachdenkt ist es natürlich so dass jetzt
die em-arena im staffel schon viel mehr
eingesetzt sind das heißt damit schwer
und auch mehr erfahrung als mit dem
nowak ist im stoff trotzdem ist das sehr
bewährtes sehr gutes konzept und stellt
sicherlich für diejenigen die jetzt mit
dem gedanken er da im stoff sich nicht
anfreunden können einfach eine gute
alternative dar wann der kommt das weiß
ich auch nicht er ist im rolling review
also wo immer wieder daten angeschaut
werden bei der ema seit februar
die zulassung ist jetzt beantragt worden
das ist so ein paar wochen her ich hoffe
mal dass der vor weihnachten noch kommt
aber da stecke ich natürlich auch nicht
drin dass ich auch noch häufiger gelesen
habe war eine gewisse skepsis wegen der
impf durchbrüche die es gab da ist juri
gagarin auf youtube mit einer frage
vertreten der sagt wie erklärt man
schließlich die hohen fallzahlen in
ländern mit sehr hoher impfquote wenn
mit impfungen die fallzahlen höher sind
als zu zeiten ohne impfung wo rund worin
liegt dann der nutzen der impfung
also das hängt natürlich einmal davon ab
welches wäre es ist gerade unterwegs sie
ansteckend ist dass und wie hoch ist die
dieses infektionsgeschehen insgesamt und
davon hängt dann auch wie viele menschen
infizieren sich ist infizieren sich
überall auf der welt mehr als geimpfte
ein proportional gesehen das ist glaube
ich unstrittig und wenn man mal anschaut
wo ist viel infektionsgeschehen und wo
es wenig infektionsgeschehen dann ist es
genau konträr zu dem wie geimpft wird
also länder mit sehr hohen importen
nehmen sie spanien als beispiel nehmen
sie portugal als beispiel wir haben sehr
niedrige infektionszahlen länder mit
niedrigeren importen haben deutlich
höhere infektionszahlen und nennen damit
ganz niedrigen quoten sehr hohe
infektionszahlen aber die impfung ist ja
nicht das einzige das hängt darf spielen
natürlich immer auch andere faktoren mit
hinein das heißt welche schutzmaßnahmen
werden gerade in dem jeweiligen land
angewendet gibt es kontakt reduktionen
gibt es keine gibt es dermaßen pflicht
gibt es keine das alles spielt in die in
das infektionsgeschehen mit 3 aber diese
korrelation in ähnlichen bereichen ist
schon sehr klar ich habe gerade von den
wissenschaftlern der analyse gesehen da
hat das mal bundesländer aufgegliedert
und da ist auch tatsächlich so
diejenigen gene hohe importe haben das
sind ja so die länder im bundesländer im
nordwesten deutschlands wir haben
deutlich weniger infektionen als
diejenigen die jetzt eher im osten oder
im süden liegen wo die impfquoten
niedriger sind also eine umgekehrte
korrelation gibt es da ganz eindeutig es
gibt noch mehr
skeptische kritische fragen frau
professor potter deswegen umso besser
dass sie heute hier bei uns in der
sendung sind ich möchte noch einen davon
aufgreifen und zwar von fred clever bei
youtube er schreibt es wird ja immer von
sicherheit gesprochen und nun wurde
angeordnet dass unter 30 jährigen nur
noch mit bayern tag geimpft werden heißt
das nicht dass monatelang falsch geimpft
wurde hätte sowas nicht vor der
zulassung der anderen impfstoffe klar
sein müssen dass
ist dass die krux mit seltenen
nebenwirkungen
bei einer zulassungsstudie sind 40.000
menschen
aufgenommen worden wenn ich jetzt eine
nebenwirkung habe die ist seltener als 1
zu 40.000 dann sähe die statistisch
nicht da brauche ich dann ein paar
hunderttausend dazu und dann gibt es
auch nebenwirkungen die sind einfach
noch seltener und die sehe ich erst dann
wenn ich eine noch größere gruppe also
vielleicht mal eine million oder auch
zehn millionen kämpft habe und genau so
ist es jetzt gewesen man hat gesehen
dass durch die vermutlich durch die
höhere dosis der mrn dem moderner
impfstoff dass dort bei jungen menschen
die mir geht es etwa häufiger ist als
bei den bio entdeckt im stoff wie ist
insgesamt immer noch sehr selten sie ist
viel seltener als nach der infektion das
ist auch wichtig zu wissen sie verläuft
meist gutartig aber wenn ich dann zwei
alternativen habe man nehme ich
natürlich diejenigen die weniger
probleme bereitet auch wenn es seltener
probleme sind und diese entscheidung ist
in den fall zu gefallen dass man gesagt
hat okay bei montech macht es einfach
seltener als moderner das macht und
deswegen geht man auch bei
zum schluss noch eine frage frau protz
wir hatten es schon angesprochen es hat
viele auch interessiert wenn denn dieser
sogenannte tod impfstoff käme fragt
matze auf youtube wie hoch ist der
schutz gegen delta wald nowaks damit
nennte einen hersteller
es gibt im moment auch nur den nowaks
hersteller der sozusagen jetzt gerade in
der in der zulassung ist
die studien sind mit dem mit der alpha
variante begonnen worden und sind jetzt
in wie delta variante fortgesetzt worden
und der schutz ich habe die finalen
daten auch noch nicht gesehen weil sich
publiziert sind bisher scheint auch bei
der delta variante weiterhin über 90% zu
sein also das ist immer noch ein sehr
wirksamer impfstoff
alle impfstoffe alles was wir bisher
machen es bei delta etwas weniger
wirksam aber das heißt ich weiß es
gleich nicht mehr wirksam ist sondern
der abfall ist halt so prozent jeweils
und insofern denke ich ist es immer noch
eine gute alternative auch wenn wir
jetzt geld da haben und das wäre wäre
ich - wenn
ich hab doch noch eine frage an sie zum
schluss das hat sich dann doch noch hier
was angesammelt es gibt nämlich dann
durch mehrere bemerkungen jetzt auch in
sachen booster impfung das ist ja was
was hier vielleicht jetzt eben auf
mehrere sehr viele menschen zukommt also
wie normal ist das vielleicht dass man
einfach mehrere impfungen brauch bei
einem impfstoff weil sich viele wundern
dass man also jetzt noch mal ein wüster
brauch das gerne noch zum schluss
also dass sich eine dritte impfung
brauche ist was was eben jetzt bei
impfstoffen eher normal ist wenn ich mir
andere doch wer anschauen wenn ich mehr
tetanus anschaue wenn ich eine polio
anschaue wenn ich mir keuchhusten
anschauen wenn ich mehr hepatitis b
anschauen ich brauche immer drei
impfungen warum weil ich mit der ersten
impfung bereit ich mein immunsystem vor
da habe ich noch kaum effekt war das bei
der zweiten impfung reagiert mein
immunsystem dann aber erst der dritte in
frottee muss dann tatsächlich gewissen
abstand erfolgen das macht man nicht so
bei fast allen impfungen etwa nach sechs
monaten oder vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen länger da werden die
gedächtniszellen dann noch mal daran
erinnert dass da etwas ist auch was sie
besonders aufpassen müssen also mich
wundert dass überhaupt nicht dass wir
eine dritte impfung brauchen
wir wissen es ja auch schon seit einer
weile da gibt es ja aus mehreren ländern
inzwischen schon ganz gute studien jetzt
auch für die saas corona virusimpfstoffe
wir sind auch aus der erfahrung einfach
von vielen anderen impfstoffen dass das
notwendig ist